so this was submitted by joey ramona on
instagram
they want us to react to jean-claude van
damme's
instagram page with this video as the
start
let's see it's just him kind of vibing
out
[Applause]
you want to see the smile
i'm very happy i was not thought
i was thinking
um i was focused
what because
i love a guy talking about final
solutions
[Music]
tomorrow will be announced but be happy
because the solution is there
can you believe that not from me
it's from me and a group
of people who are fantastic that you're
going to love
and also something else which is very
powerful right now
yeah his eyes and he's high yeah no
dude look at his eyes i know what i have
never seen the documentary on show time
you know like three years do a bunch of
code nine it will work i promise you
it will work if not i'm not worth
to exist yeah that's a nice little
straight he threw
a little uppercut this is like a
two-minute video oh
hell yeah like he is oh [ __ ] he danced
like my uncle
hell yeah don't get lost in the sauce
you hurt
[Applause]
i think he was on instagram live and
then they give you an option where you
can save that whole instagram live video
afterwards
so you don't see the uh comments and
stuff i think that's who he's addressing
i like how he came in with it that's
somebody's uncle hey
uh who was this his last poster did he
update
uh i think he has two more posts after
how old is he
she deliver everything oh he has a
couple oh damn
oh he's 60. i love that's a dope b
day picture oh good uppercut oh wait you
know that leg can get up there do that
hold on play that again
um between one bro you know that leg and
get up high look at that
damn he landed it hard he saw the next
day
between 1000 to 1500
gallons a day which is about
six to seven thousand five hundred
liters someone checked a day so
if you want to see more of him he has a
youtube channel now oh hell yeah
about what he said what i don't know
diesel need a collab
oh yeah vanisho is trying to get on tick
tock now
say less he doesn't show his subscribers
either oh you can show it yeah you can
choose
but this that's a good amount of views
200 000. i thought that was harvey from
tmz
wow interesting oh yeah his face doesn't
look like it yeah so what is he just
he's really high i don't know i assume
so watch
crazy yeah i'd say he's high yeah
damn when you get high you just be
talking about anything
oh man i did that he has a music video
wait wait wait wait you talked about it
a while ago we did
we yeah yeah we did
you said you wanted to recreate it at
one of your tours
yeah when i got off stage at the laugh
actually
right away you go bro i figured out what
you look like i'm like what this wrote a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son